here's what I want to do I want to
investigate this space in here okay I
want to see what's happening so as we're
I'm going to try and zoom in okay
underneath this I'm going to ask you to
draw another table values this one
probably doesn't need to be as large
okay now this is tricky because this
techniques we've used before just trying
to you know put numbers in randomly has
not given us as much information as we'd
like so we need to be a little more
directed and purposeful in this I want
to check what's happening between 0 & 1
I don't need to check during one again I
already know what happens for those so I
want some fractions between 0 & 1 and I
want to choose some useful ones okay now
do you remember how over here see these
guys over here
I didn't pick them at random I chose
them very deliberately 1 2 4 & 8 the
next one would have been 16 now when I
put that one into 32
why did I choose those numbers have a
think about this one two four and eight
eighths on a square one two four and
eight I'll just I'm just going to hold
on I really want to make sure you don't
get that moment where you're like I
don't get it I don't understand I see a
thing but I don't understand if you pay
attention I could help you understand I
chose each of these guys because they
are each a power of two this is 3 to the
power of 0 to the power of 1 too scared
to cube the next one would have been 2
to the power of 4 which is 16 then to
the power 5 which is 32 and so on does
that make sense so I want to choose
powers of 2 between 0 & 1 here's one of
them see that guy
between zero one isn't it that's a power
of two what's another power of two that
I could pick in here yeah a quarter now
interestingly I usually go from left to
right yeah but a half is bigger than a
quarter isn't it
so a quarter is smaller so maybe instead
of a half being here
our guys settle down I've betrayed you
so I'm going to put a half over here
Ryan then suggested a quarter Brian and
then an eight and then a sixteen okay so
we already know what happens for this
one
we already know for a half what's the
power that goes with a half you know one
there it is what do you think the power
goes with a quarter
okay so now we've got enough information
this is finally enough I've got this
space down the bottom now what I'm going
to do is construct this quite carefully
you remember we notice these negative
values over here they're good so instead
of can you maybe just wait and watch
because your page will look great and
then you'll have no idea where we're at
which is a problem we're going to draw a
bit of a different set of axes usually
we draw both sides but I don't need to
draw any of this negative side did you
remember that like they're all giving us
nothing useful so I'm going to draw a
graph that looks like this
see how I've got the y-axis here and the
x-axis here but I've only got these
those of X okay another reason why I
cannae to make that type so much bigger
is look at the x-values Jesus they go up
pretty quickly right so they're going to
go all the way up to eight whereas my Y
values are going to be smaller okay so I
think
let's have a look okay this far one two
three three okay so you can see on my
y-axis I go three up and three down
whoops should have the most important
spot there on my x-axis I go all the way
up to eight because that's the biggest
number that I have there okay so let's
start to plot the points that we know
let's do it in the order that they're
actually written left to right because
those are the orders we actually
calculated video okay so the first point
that we write is over here when X is one
y equals zero so 1 comma 0 1 comma 0 is
one of the points on my graph where is 1
comma 0 how would you describe it use
some words it's on the x axis the
horizontal axis and it's very good the
first point right there there's 1 comma
0 don't bother labeling it because we
going to have a lot of points on here
get too busy ok this next one is 2 comma
1
yeah so I'm going to go across 2 units
and up 1 so on my graph that looks like
than that mess ok the next one is 4
comma 2 the one that is 8 comma 3 go
ahead and draw those in not just yet
we'll connect them all together at the
end ok so these are the values these are
the points we got out of the first table
but then you remember we said we were
like yeah we don't know what's going on
in here so that's why we kind of zoomed
in all the V values are between 0 and 1
ok now we calculated these but on my
graph I actually don't have enough to
fit this first one so I'm going to go to
this one when X is equal to what over 8
y is equal to negative 3 ok so whatever
it is quite close over here right
because if you went half way then half
way again then half way again
you could see how close you are to the
answers and my board is obviously a lot
bigger than your page as a good shot
okay so QC I'm going to be somewhere
around here
very very close to the axis one it is
pretty small right that was the first
one
what's the second last one over there
what are the coordinates a quarter and
negative two so that's about there a
little bit further over not much though
and then the last one over there is our
half comma negative one so that's around
a half way between zero one okay now can
you see the shake you can see it mapped
out we've got enough points you can
almost even without drawing it you can
see what shape it is okay tell me is
that a straight line it's clearly not a
straight line so you're going to have a
curve that passes through there use a
pencil connect the dots as closely as
you can and see what you get
okay now this is pretty cool because
it's a very interesting shape we should
label it by the way this is y equals log
base two of X it has a single intercept
an x intercept what's its value have a
look the x intercept
it's just 1 1 comma 0 are the
coordinates ok ah why don't I see any y
intercept think why can't I find one
have a look
run yeah see this see this guy here to
find a y-intercept you let X equal 0 but
we're investigating we found that X can
never be 0 there's no value of y that
matches up to it and we have a name for
this ray we have a name for what happens
when you get closer and closer and
closer to these which you can never get
there such an aid what is that with an
asymptote right right here can you draw
in in a dotted line that's the asymptote
okay
the equation of the asymptote is x
equals 0 ok the equation of the
asymptote is x equals 0